still God tear the way Statham says it
it's a Megalodon
[Music]
two
minutes to a half an hour long and it's
generally speaking imperfectly so
the spring break shark Massacre you
might be hoping to say the rest of the
movie leading up to that it's about an
hour and 15 minutes snooze Fest it feels
like a dollar store version of the Abyss
that's it that's the review I feel like
I don't need to save much more than that
but I'm going to why algorithm maybe
it's like it's two different movies it's
the Meg 2 and it's the trench but more
trench than Meg too the Meg 2 does it
bigger but bigger isn't always better it
has more Megs and more locations and
more
walking on the bottom of the ocean which
could be cool but it just feels like
they didn't know what to do with it in a
movie titled the Meg 2 with more Megs
does that mean more Carnage not yet
first you got to get past more corporate
Espionage mercenaries hostage situations
more things that just you're like
where's the shark Carnage and by the
time the shark Carnage does come you're
like okay we're gonna get to that shark
blood bath we're here for well it is
PG-13 so it's less blood more
bath rated R does not always mean better
but I think if you do have a shark movie
in which the movie is building to this
spring break bunch of people on the
beach and here come the Megs and other
monsters I I feel like you should have
more payoff with that I get why it's
PG-13 because you make a movie like this
rated R you cut out an entire Target
demographic one could argue the Target
demographic this film is made for on the
other hand it did feel like it was a
made for TV Carnage Fest where it's like
Meg's eating everybody no blood though
can't have that it just felt like the
movie didn't have any teeth I didn't I
didn't mean that to be a pun
when the last act's going down and you
you have a bunch of monsters just
attacking people you couldn't help but
see what the movie could have been you
got monsters from the trench that can
walk on land now you brought a kraken
into it because why not so you got Megs
you got little sea land monsters and you
got Krakens they're all just having a
good time why not have that be a full 90
minute movie where Jason Statham and his
crew are trying to do that I got it you
want build up in your film but this film
didn't have build up you just had
boredom you can tell some of the actors
in the movie are leaning into the cheese
factor I appreciate that they're giving
it that shot but it just wasn't enough
it couldn't keep the film from falling
flat it's like this movie is a
hodgepodge of other script ideas that
never got green lit they just took those
and put them into this Meg 2 movie Die
Hard on a water base didn't happen it's
in the Meg too Die Hard in an underwater
water base slightly different
we're gonna put that in the Meg too and
we're gonna kind of have an ending like
the mag was gonna be wrapped up in some
Jurassic world [__] there we go
the Meg 2 the trench we all know
appreciate and love the phenomenon that
can happen with a movie like this known
as it's so bad it's good or at the very
least entertaining
this is not that no to craft that
phenomenon is a skill it's either skill
or you accidentally fumble [__] your way
into it probably in a decade known as
the 90s this is so bad because it's just
boring it's it's a boring film with
uninteresting characters that have [__]
decision making skills a shoddy script
in a film with choppy editing it's as
simple as that this does have that fun
cheese factor in the last 20 minutes or
so of it keeps me from hating this film
like to my very bone marrow in the end
I'm still not gonna remember it in
T-minus one day it's a Megalodon all
right so the Meg 2 the trench have you
seen it what did you think about it
what's your favorite Grade B monster
movie or Monster movie that's
accidentally Grade B whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]